[Music]
[Music]
I'm sure you've seen the headlines fish
oil makes you smarter blueberries can
stave off dementia chocolate cures
depression we seem to be overly eager to
embrace the idea that there are certain
foods brain food if you will that can
improve our brains function whether
that's because what we eat can influence
our mood or can be rewarding or even
ease me fix there's clearly an appeal to
the notion that what we put in our
mouths has a direct influence on our
brains and that purported mechanism by
which these superfoods might influence
our minds have gotten increasingly
specific with advertisements using terms
like neuroplasticity synaptic repair and
neuro trophic factors to give their
claims gravitas but what do the data
show is there any credible evidence that
we should be swallowing blueberries by
the mouth full and how should we
evaluate the evidence that does exist
how ultimately does what we put in our
mouths end up in our brains these are
the questions we'll explore in this
lecture and along the way we'll test out
the myths associated with brain food
specifically addressing fish oil
vitamins and power drinks and
antioxidants like chocolate and green
tea but let's start by examining why
food fads make headlines you can boil
this conundrum down to three words cheap
easy and tasty wouldn't we love to just
take a pill and get smarter it sounds
silly when put like that but it's so
easy to convince ourselves that eating
goji berries will increase our brains
processing speed or something like that
but if they don't work why do we keep
seeing products with outrageous claims
on their labels a famous case in point
was the company that
made drinks with the prefix neuro whose
logo includes a head with some kind of
wave inside it presumably representing
neural activity with the neuro sonic
drink the company calls their
proprietary blend of ingredients
including caffeine modern Sciences
greatest blend of natural mental
performance enhancers Get Smart drink
neuro they suggest it's pretty simple to
test claims of cognitive enhancement in
a well-designed study double-blind
placebo-controlled but the company has
yet to publish such an experiment well
it's adding caffeine to a drink in a
pretty bottle can make it fly off the
shelves why bother with the study it's
hard to make money off of readily
available food you can't patent
blueberries and that means that
expensive clinical trials on their
efficacy are hard to fund which means
that we don't have a regulatory body
like the FDA helping us separate the
wheat from the chaff it's hard to find
data on the effects of different
specific foods on brain function hard
but not impossible
one way you might say is just to ask
people to participate in studies that
test their brain function and track what
they eat simple enough until you
consider that the types of people who
can afford to volunteer for such studies
remember there probably isn't much money
to pay them so most survey studies are
limited to people with a moderate to
high socioeconomic status the second
problem is that you need to control the
dosage or ingredients in whatever it is
that you're studying so for example
let's say you're interested in studying
the effects of resveratrol which is an
antioxidant found in red wine well for
such a study you need to know exactly
how much red wine is being consumed you
can't just ask people to report how many
glasses they drink the size of my glass
might be very different from the size of
yours the gold standard a double-blind
placebo-controlled study is expensive
but ultimately that's the own
we kind of evidence that can really
evaluate the effect of a particular food
on brain function so as we talk about
the results of specific studies let's
keep these constraints in mind
and speaking of minds what do we know
about how nutrients reach the brain
well you might remember that the way
nutrients reach brain cells is a bit
different from the rest of the body
that's because brain cells are precious
we don't want to lose them because they
don't replenish the way say our skin
cells do our experiences are written
into the physical and physiological
features of our neurons and we don't
want to lose our memory of our
grandmother for example because we ate a
bad oyster which obviously is impossible
but you get the point the immune system
largely functions by killing cells
infected with foreign invaders well we
can't use that system in the brain the
same way that we use it in the rest of
the body so instead of sending out
troops of killer cells Nature built a
fortress around the brain called the
blood-brain barrier it's essentially
just a network of blood vessels with
cells that are much more tightly packed
preventing large molecules from being
able to cross into the brain but that
means that important nutrients are also
shut out so the brain has a complex
system of cells that do security checks
letting in the good nutrients and
passing them along to the right brain
cells and keeping out the suicide
bombers for the most part you might also
remember that the brain is hungry it's a
metabolically costly organ taking up
only 2% of body mass but guzzling around
20% of its fuel that's why it's hard to
think when your blood sugar is low but
providing glucose is not the only way
that food can influence the brain it
also provides certain cellular building
materials that can play a role in
neuroplasticity how cells change with
experience these changes can even
include epigenetics switching genes on
and off and affecting how they're
expressed meaning that what you eat can
ultimately shape your brain let me show
you how
foods for example can trigger the
release of certain hormones that can
then affect brain function one of these
hormones is called BDNF brain-derived
neurotrophic factor and it plays a
starring role in our first food study
BDNF is one of my favorite proteins so
let me take a minute to tell you why it
has a number of jobs one of which is to
guide and promote the growth of new
neurons and the connections between them
it's very active in my favorite brain
region the hippocampus which is where
our short-term memories are turned into
long-term ones the hippocampus is our
window both to the past and to the
future we need it to travel backward in
time in our memory and forward in time
in our imagination pretty awesome
because it plays a big role in shaping
the hippocampus BDNF is important for
long-term memory formation if you put an
animal human or otherwise
in an enriching environment for example
more B D and s will be produced in his
brain leading to more synapses more
dendrites and more neurons themself the
ultimate effect of which is that the
animal learns more it gets smarter than
an animal raised in an impoverished
environment whose brain has lower levels
of BDNF and fewer of these changes so is
there any connection between B D and s
levels and the food we eat well
the key ingredient in fish oil is
omega-3 polyunsaturated acid
specifically docos EXO Noack acid or DHA
and you might have heard claims that is
good for your brain you can find it an
oily fish like salmon mackerel and
sardines or you can take it as a
supplement and yes DHA is thought to
play a role in brain development by
increasing expression of BDNF this is
why women who are pregnant are
encouraged to take DHA and you can find
infant formulas with DHA supplements
added in from work with rodents we know
that omega-3 fatty acids turn on genes
that help keep the signaling system
between brain cells working properly
and enable neuroplasticity or the types
of physical changes that drive learning
DHA is the most prevalent fatty acid in
brain cell membranes the protective
covering that keeps the good stuff
inside the cell and the bad stuff out
but that also plays a major role in
signaling between cells and there's some
evidence that our ability to add DHA to
our diets with a turning point in our
evolutionary history helping our brains
to grow in size compared with the rest
of our body increasing the brain to body
mass ratio or encephalization quotient
oh and DHA is also an antioxidant we'll
talk about antioxidants in a few minutes
but it seems like a pretty good
candidate for a brain food right so
what's the evidence that taking fish oil
will make you smarter or even stave off
decline let me read you the beginning of
a typical media piece published in 2012
on a major news site fish oils do make
children brainy runs the headline it
continues parents should give their
children a daily dose of fish oils if
they want to boost brainpower and stop
them being naughty Wow
where do I sign up going on scientists
at Oxford University found that taking a
Dayla daily omega-3 fatty acid
supplement improved not only the reading
ability but also behavior of primary
school children the study in the journal
PLoS ONE compared daily supplements of
omega-3 rich docos XM Noack acid DHA
with a placebo pretty compelling so
let's take a little closer look into the
study the design was a randomized
double-blind placebo-controlled study of
healthy seven to nine year old kids so
far so good they started out as
underperformers in reading okay that
leaves room for improvement right but it
also begs the question of what caused
them to have difficulty reading in the
first place the results no effect of DHA
on the full sample but in a subset of
the worst readers that
percentile and below the researchers did
find reading benefits and parents rated
their children is better behaved but
critically neither measures of working
memory nor teacher rated behavior were
different compared with the placebo
group so it's a pretty subtle finding
it's exciting to find that we can
improve reading ability in the kids who
most need help with a pretty simple
intervention but it's also possible that
they're having trouble reading in part
because they're malnourished and there's
no evidence that for kids who are
average readers supplementing their diet
with DHA makes any difference to
cognition or behavior so maybe omega-3
fatty acids aren't the brain boosters we
thought they were for all kids what
about for older adults we also often
hear about the power of omega-3s to
stave off cognitive effects of aging do
they well they do hold some promise
since older adults particularly those
who go on to develop Alzheimer's disease
tend to experience a decrease in levels
of DHA in their brains so scientists
have wondered whether this decrease
plays a role in the cognitive decline
that can accompany aging animals who are
deprived of DHA show problems with
learning which are then resolved if
they're given a supplement DHA
supplements are recommended by the
American Heart Association because they
seem to reduce the risk of coronary
artery disease and cardiovascular
problems contribute to cognitive decline
eating a lot of fish also seems to be
associated with a lower risk of stroke
they also reduce inflammation which has
been associated with neurodegenerative
diseases like Alzheimer's and omega-3s
might even play a direct role in
decreasing Alzheimer's pathology since
they reduce amyloid production and the
plaques that are a signature of disease
are made up of amyloid but a randomized
placebo-controlled double-blind study
published in Neurology in 2008 in which
302 healthy individuals aged 65 and
older participated the authors found no
affective DHA supplements on cognitive
function even after 26 weeks of taking
them and in a 2009 review of 11
observational and for clinical trials
but researchers at Johns Hopkins and
UCSF published in the nature club in the
nature clinical practice the authors
were surprised to find little evidence
of any positive effect in the prevention
or treatment of dementia they did report
some modest benefit in slowing decline
in healthy elderly participants so
perhaps for people at risk of developing
AD who are labeled as having mild
cognitive impairment there may be some
benefit as a randomized
placebo-controlled trial of patients
over the age of 55 published in 2010
found a little like the kids in the
lowest reading percentile older adults
who are vulnerable seem to show some
positive effects but people who are
healthy to begin with or those already
showing symptoms are not likely to find
themselves suddenly brainer so what can
we say about fish oil it likely won't
make a difference
unless you're pregnant under the age of
1 or at risk of showing cognitive
impairment either in childhood or in old
age I don't want to diminish the
potential benefits of staving off
decline but in this lecture we're
examining whether brain food actually
makes you smarter and there doesn't seem
to be any evidence of that
for DHA so much for omega-3 fatty acids
but what about other antioxidants we
often hear good things about green tea
coffee chocolate red wine blueberries
and strawberries all of which contain
antioxidants and are often labeled
superfoods is there any evidence that
they can boost our brains certainly lots
of companies that market specialty
drinks would like you to think so how
might antioxidants helped our cognitive
function well in a nutshell they're
involved in helping brain cells get
nutrients from the blood and in
neuroplasticity but they're best known
for defusing the little bombs that
result from normal chemical reactions
free radicals
oxygen is the stuff of life of course
but too much of it can be toxic no you
can't breathe yourself to death though
if you are getting oxygen from a
supplemental source when you're scuba
diving for example you can take in too
much oxygen and that can ultimately
cause problems like seizures we need
oxygen to extract energy from our food a
process that leaves behind metabolic
byproducts like free radicals these are
atoms that are electrically unstable we
have an unpaired electron and because of
this instability free radicals can strip
an electron from another nearby molecule
as they travel through the body they can
then wreak havoc by creating more
unstable molecules in their wake this
domino effect is how free radicals can
damage cells ripping through them like a
tornado and too many free radicals in a
person's body can become a problem
that's why the body has natural defenses
to protect against the proliferation of
these little bombs cells can keep free
radicals pinned in with physical
boundaries we have enzymes that
neutralized oxygen gone awry and of
course antioxidants from our diet can
donate their electrons to stop the chain
reaction that's all part of the normal
metabolic process but the question at
hand is whether more antioxidants will
enhance brain function or even protected
from decline studies and animal models
do show some positive effects of adding
antioxidants to the diet but the data
from human studies are mixed smaller
studies have reported some effects but
once those studies are replicated with
larger sample sizes the effects tend to
go away which means that there are
likely other variables affecting the
results in the smaller samples for
example one study in 2012 found a
positive effect on cognition in people
who ate more blueberries and
strawberries but people who have access
to these relatively expensive fruits are
better off and likely pay more attention
to their diets and lifestyle x-rays
more perhaps which we know affects
cognition and on the troubling side
studies have also shown that taking too
much of an antioxidant like vitamin E
for example can have negative side
effects like an increased risk of
prostate cancer there can be too much of
a good thing and taking vitamin
supplements is a good example of it
vitamins are a thirty billion or so
dollar business with surveys showing
that some fifty percent of Americans are
taking them and in 1988 an influential
placebo controlled study of twelve to
thirteen year olds showed an improvement
in nonverbal IQ for kids who took them
but since then the evidence is building
that adding vitamins to a healthy diet
doesn't help the brain even so research
does indicate that poor nutrition can
harm cognitive function so for kids who
are in danger of not getting enough
nutrients from their diet vitamins are a
good idea for everyone else it doesn't
seem to make a measurable difference so
we've talked about fish oil anti axe
oxidants and vitamins but what about
brain boosting drinks like those with
the prefix neuro in their names that we
talked about at the top of the lecture
you might have seen these bottles in
your local health food store marketing
better sleep sharper wits and less
stress some of these even contained
neurotransmitters and hormones but buyer
beware these drinks are classified of
dietary supplements not food or drugs so
they don't need FDA approval or even
safety testing to tout their benefits in
2016 neuro Brands LLC agreed to pay five
hundred thousand dollars in fines and
restitution in a legal settlement as
they were forced to change their
marketing this was in response to a
civil complaint alleging that there was
no scientific evidence to back up any of
their claims so there's not much
evidence that you can drink your way to
a better brain unless your drink is
laced with caffeine here we do have a
brain booster at our fingertips
some historians have even suggested that
the proliferation of coffee houses in
Europe in the middle of the 17th century
assured in the Enlightenment and
ultimately the Industrial Revolution
well when beer was the drink of choice
during the day coffee must have seemed
like the great cognitive enhancer and
coffee houses became places where
intellectuals gathered to exchange new
ideas but looking beyond its possible
impact on history what if science tell
us about caffeine and our brains well a
large study from 2002 found that higher
lifetime caffeine intake was associated
with better performance and older adults
on at least 6 of 12 tests of cognitive
function so notably this effect was only
found in women but if you're male don't
worry a later study from 2007 of
European men found that coffee drinkers
had a slower rate of cognitive decline
than those who abstained from caffeine
and in a study from 2009 moderate coffee
drinkers of both genders in midlife were
found to have a lower risk of developing
dementia and Alzheimer's disease later
in life can coffee stave off disease
well it's hard to say as of yet does
coffee leave a person more alert and
able to complete cognitive tasks and
thus score higher on such measures most
likely yes does it prevent plaques and
tangles which are the pathological
markers of Alzheimer's disease probably
not so caffeine might have a protective
effect but it remains unclear whether
it's a direct physiological mechanism
like reducing inflammation for example
or more related to increasing cognitive
resources like helping you focus better
on the task at hand so here again the
story is one of moderation because one
thing we do know that can lead to
increased Alzheimer's pathology is sleep
deprivation so as too much caffeine is
interfering with your sleep that's not
good and that brings us to our next
topic if we can't find a way to
boost our brains by adding things to our
diets what about taking things away here
my friends is a sad story one that I
tell a little reluctantly there does
seem to be some evidence that caloric
restriction eating substantially less
than most of us do may enhance cognition
and even extend your lifespan so I often
wonder whether the cost is worth it in
mouse models restricting calories
significantly by having them fast every
other day has been shown to improve
cognitive function and protect against
Alzheimer's Parkinson's Huntington's
other diseases and Stroke
what's more fasting while maintaining
essential vitamins and other nutrients
via supplements can induce the growth of
more new neurons in mice that's called
neurogenesis it can also positively
affect their neuroplasticity
the physical changes that cells undergo
during learning which might bend stave
off age-related cognitive decline and
restore function if the brain is injured
even just delaying the next meal seems
to enhance intelligence in mice even
when the ultimate calorie intake is the
same it seems that fasting can stimulate
the production of certain proteins and
hormones that improve function like B D
and s for example the star protein that
we talked about earlier evidence for the
cognitive benefits of caloric
restriction is plentiful among rodents
and there's some encouraging evidence
from studies involving humans and other
primates but the data here are mixed one
reason why we still don't know how
caloric restriction affects primates is
because our diets are so variable one
early study in monkeys for example found
a significant effect when the monkeys
were fed the equivalent of a junk food
diet in that case those who ate less
were better off but when monkeys were
put on a very healthy diet the effects
of restricting calories was mild or
non-existent we see the same in humans
of course not enough food is bad for
your brain too much unhealthy food is
also bad for your brain but we don't yet
know whether restricting calories in toe
can keep your brain young in fact one
global critique of the caloric
restriction literature is that even the
mouse studies are usually comparing
animals on a restricted diet with those
who can eat however much they want yeah
the restricted animals live longer than
those feeding ad libitum but already
affects due in part to the fact that the
unrestricted animals gain too much
weight the truth is is that we don't
know yet there is one pill so to speak
that does seem to reliably stave off
cognitive decline trigger the production
of BDNF and other helpful proteins and
boost your brain exercise in fact in now
classic experiments rodents that were
raised in an enriched environment with
more toys and other things in their
cages only showed a measurable increase
in BDNF and neurogenesis if they were
also provided with running wheels in
humans exercise also increases BDNF and
that might be the mechanism by which it
protects against neurodegenerative
diseases consistent aerobic exercise
increases the amount of grey matter in
your brain especially in the hippocampus
and prefrontal cortex which are
responsible for memory and cognitive
control if blueberries were as effective
we'd all be consuming them by the bushel
in fact walking has been shown to have
as big if not a bigger effect on
cognition in 70 and 80 year olds than
vitamins or other supplements so the
brain needs food and it needs exercise
but there's no compelling evidence yet
that some super foods are brain boosters
what about the other direction I can't
tell you how many times I've heard
parents attribute bad behavior in their
kids to sugar intake give a kid a
cupcake and she'll turn into a gremlin
right well maybe not as far back as 1995
a meta-analysis was designed to examine
the effects of sugar on the behavior and
cognition of children by then 23 studies
had already been conducted to address
the issue the final word no effect
when studies were carefully controlled
for expectation effects and measures
were objective consuming sugar had no
effect on most children and a study in
2006 replicated these results preschool
children were given either chocolate or
fruit and then videotaped these
videotapes were then watched by
objective raters who didn't know what
the children had consumed they found no
differences in behavior between kids
that ate chocolate and those who ate
fruit wait a minute you might be
thinking I've witnessed five-year-olds
at a birthday party their behavior is
monstrous but that's likely because
they're already overexcited the balloons
the scary clown the social interaction
so on it's not just the sugar and
remember that these are short-term
studies not studies of long-term
consumption of junk food long-term
studies do find negative effects of junk
food on cognition one study for example
tracked whether diet at age four
influences behavior at age seven and
here yes kids who had a diet high in
junk food eating chocolate bars and
chips four times a week were more
hyperactive and therefore less able to
concentrate and focus in class than kids
who had healthier diets at age seven
this has social implications of course
since kids of lower SES tend to consume
more junk food indeed the problem may
not be too much sugar but it might be
malnutrition in general since these same
kids are more likely to have litter
little or no omega-3 fatty acids for
instance in their diets
so maybe we can now put the brain food
myth largely to rest after several
decades of research we're not much
further along than what our grandparents
already knew eating a healthy diet and
getting a daily constitutional is good
for your brain excessive consumption of
pretty much anything is not but there's
another quiet revolution worth
considering pills that enhance your
brain these so called nootropics or
smart pills seem
to be more and more commonly used by
healthy people and the billion dollar
industry that supplies them is
blossoming most nootropics are
stimulants like caffeine that boost
cognition essentially by stating off
fatigue and thereby increasing mental
focus
these include drugs like adderall
ritalin and modafinil adderall and
Ritalin are traditionally prescribed for
the treatment of ADHD attention deficit
hyperactivity disorder by 2016
some 10% or more of kids aged 3 to 17
were being diagnosed and given
prescriptions of Ritalin or adderall
these kids grew up to the adults of
course and about 50% of them still
report symptoms so as these kids grow up
and move into careers many of them
continue taking these cognitive
enhancers even psychologists aren't
immune to the allure of the drugs in
fact in 2007 two prominent psychologists
at Cambridge University wrote a letter
to nature flagging the use of modafinil
by colleagues to stay competitive
adderall ritalin and modafinil are all
controlled substances in the US because
of their high potential for abuse they
all prevent brain cells from reabsorbing
the neurotransmitters norepinephrine and
dopamine which leaves more of them
available for use by the cells they
might seem harmless but they do have
side effects including sleep problems
anxiety headaches dizziness and an
increased heart rate among others we
don't allow our professional athletes to
take steroids and artificially boost
their muscle mass we do let them have a
cup of coffee or an energy drink so
various smart pills fall on this
continuum is it just a better cup of
coffee no you might argue it's a
controlled substance because it's
addictive well so is coffee as I'm very
well aware I don't have the answer to
the question of just how much regulation
should be applied to smart pills nor can
I predict how ubiquitous you might
become the next few decades will they
assure in the next revolution just as
coffee
supposedly did and enlightened Europe or
will some other brain booster take over
the industry
time will tell but there's one thing
that I can guarantee we won't stop
trying to make our brains better